foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Jade Washington
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money it's a free call and
some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it the phone number is
888-825-5225 that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five Tiffany in
Gainesville Florida starts this hour hi
Tiffany how are you
hi Dave how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
so my question is um I have been on the
Dave Ramsey plan for about 22 months so
I'm coming up on two years I've paid off
about a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in debt wow but I'm good job you
have a little bit of ways to go
um so my question is in this day and
time should I sell my home so
um I had about a hundred and ninety
thousand dollars in equity maybe 210
depending on how it would sell
um and I have about two hundred and
twenty three thousand dollars of
Consumer Debt that includes medical
bills a forty three thousand dollar car
credit cards and then some divorce
penalties I had so my question is would
that Propel me would that be a better
idea unfortunately increasing my income
anymore isn't an option right now
um I make about 139 good for you I bring
home about 139. how long were you
married
since I was 16 so 20
too long 24 and a half years wow and
then you've been divorced how long
um
five years six months
sure yeah
okay
I'm sorry you went through that uh
sounds like you really scratching and
clawing your way back I'm proud of you
it's a process
training last week but there's no more
areas in the budget I've sold everything
I can sell so my options are to keep you
know scratching forward or to sell my
house and kind of get rid of the
Consumer Debt the unfortunate part is
did you have the house uh before Mary
before the divorce I didn't I okay you
have do you have children do my divorce
grown just one okay good okay
so do you like the house
I love the house it's perfect it's a
good would be a good place to even
retire
um
it's just
I have had to stop paying on three
consumer debts
um once they came I put you should never
do this I'm sure you're gonna cringe as
I was went do a very significant illness
and during chemo I was still very ill
and I kept getting calls you gotta pay
this you got to pay this I put it on my
credit cards so I have some credit card
debt but once it came out of the
interest-free period which is about
three months ago I wasn't able to make
minimum payments
um so I I still paid my regular payment
but obviously it's already negatively
impacted me so I'm scratching at other
alternatives to kind of get back ahead
so those are the you said it was three
credit cards that's the only outstanding
payments right
now yes but you're just struggling to
make the minimum extra yeah yeah okay
um so how were you able to pay off 130
and now you got no margin so that's my
question um
so I cashed out my 401k
[Music]
um
I catch on my 401k because I have much
cash settlement
um 290 000 but I had to make a cash
settlement for my divorce so that I
didn't have to pay alimony
so that's where that came from and had I
known that I was about to
um
come out of our mission and need
chemother treatment and two more
surgeries I obviously would have never
done that but unfortunately
um
you know so you just do better with it
so how much is your house payment
um 2407 how much is your car payment
712.
how much do you still owe on that car
like if you sold it if you sold it today
would you what would you get for it well
the unfortunate part is I would only get
about 12 000 that's based on Kelly blue
but because of the mileage on the
vehicle because unfortunately how did
you turn a forty thousand dollar debt
into a twelve thousand dollar car yeah
yes so unfortunately mileage so mileage
mileage doesn't do that
you must have had negative equity going
in or you got bad information somewhere
did you roll it no I took it you can't
put enough miles on a car to do that
I have a 158 000. I don't have to do
that
that's what Kelly Blue Book
and you owe 45.
oh 43.
somebody's numbers are wrong somewhere
did you have negative equity another car
you rolled into this one I didn't have
an
I haven't interesting I would double
just something wrong humor me and double
check that when you get a chance because
that doesn't feel right it is a lot of
miles but it doesn't seem like that many
miles
what's your interest rate
6.6
so that's an actual payoff number not a
top total of payments
oh that's likely correct that is my
current balance that reports to my
Credit Karma
uh Credit Karma doesn't count
okay they got Bad Karma so um no you
need to actually call the bank and find
out what your actual payoff is because
that they may be reporting there's two
ways to calculate a subprime loan this
doesn't sound like a subprom loan they
calculate it as an actual payoff balance
or a top total of all payments remaining
which would be much higher if that's the
number then the actual payoff number is
going to be like 30 and then your 12 is
wrong still so you're a lot closer than
we thought that's what I'm thinking is
going on because these numbers don't
work there's no way you get there with
this number so anyway
um what's the least amount that you can
live on because I'm looking at your debt
and I'm looking at what you earn and I'm
like maybe she can be free you know uh
four years I'm looking at and there is
something to be said for
um cutting your budget as much as you
can cut it getting your income as high
up as you can get it and then whatever
that margin is you just have to ride
that horse to the Finish Line like there
is something to be said for that I don't
know that you're there
um here's here's what's going through my
head okay
cancer and a divorce
Quick Fix with the 401K now Quick Fix
with the house
and you still never address the person
in your mirror because you've had so
much tragedy in so many things there's
so you're so much pain that I want you
to make sure if you sell this house that
you don't that you do address the budget
and that you quit finding ways to find
yourself into this because you use the
word unfortunately like four times to
outline stupid things you had done those
were not unfortunate they were bad
choices you're not stupid but you've
been in a lot of different kinds of pain
in the last five years and I'm sorry I
know you're hurting so I just don't want
to add to your pain so I usually we
usually tell people don't sell the house
if you do to get out of this and I
really wouldn't blame you here to be out
of it and to be free and start a whole
healing campaign in every area of your
life make sure you heal in the financial
area and you live on less than you make
from this point forward and no more
unfortunately no more
now now you're gonna you're gonna get
control of these control levels you've
got to you don't have a choice now I'm
so sorry for what you've been through
hun this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America we're
glad you're here if you like what you're
hearing help us out we can use the help
click the Subscribe button the follow
button share the show any way you can
whether you just tell people about it or
whether you have some of the platforms
have a share function use it click a
link and send them a copy of the podcast
or the YouTube link whatever it is and I
tell them where we are on talk radio
however it is and leave a five star
review all of those really do help us
and if you want to say thank you to us
that's how you do it because it puts us
up at the front of the uh algorithms and
keeps the new people finding us and
we're able to help them it's what we do
Ali is with us Ali's in St Louis hi Ali
welcome to the Ramsay show
Hi how are you better than I deserve
what's up
um yeah I'm just calling um I am a
physical therapist here in St Louis I've
been out of school for about a year now
but I've been in a residency program so
I've been able to defer my loans and
last night I really sat down and figured
out that I need to start tackling these
things but I've got about 112
000 in my name from undergrad and also
from graduate PT schools and then my
parents also have about a hundred
thousand in their name that they took
out to help me get through undergrad so
I'm just kind of curious the best way to
tackle these and get out of debt as
quickly as possible is this your only
debt or do you have other types of debt
to go along with it
this is the only debt I have okay well
what I would do if I were in your shoes
is hey I'm glad that you're looking at
this and going hey I got to pay this off
I can't wait around for somebody else to
do it for me so that's good
um a lot of times these loans they're
broken into lots of smaller loans are
yours are they like that Yes mine are
yeah I've got uh all together they're
about 20 just small loans okay so
assuming that the parent Plus Loans were
like it was decided that you're the one
paying them back I'm assuming that's the
case right even though they took the
loan out
um well we haven't really had that
conversation yet so that's something
that I need to do with my parents
um so we have 112 000 are all in my name
and then 100 000 of Parent Plus Loans
what makes you think you're liable for
The Parent Plus Loans did they you
didn't have a discussion when you took
them out they said we'll take these out
but you've got to pay them that wasn't a
conversation early the conversation that
we've had is we'll help you with this
but we haven't had a fully sit-down
conversation to decide what exactly does
that mean so that is very that is like
top right your parents are not wealthy
not necessarily middle class um they do
they do okay but I wasn't putting them
down I'm just if they got 10 million
dollars in the bank they wouldn't have
done this well some people also think
that me helping you is Alco sign since
you can't sign on your own so they might
have just thought by co-signing that was
it but there's a lot of money on the
table here so I would have that
conversation and find out
um Ali did you finish residency yet
yes I finished up now so how do you make
now start 80.
let's see this past year during my
resume now what will you make this year
80. this coming year this year only
71.71 okay plus you can pick up some OT
uh if not with that firm with uh
whatever uh emergency room or whatever
right
yeah so we can we can use this degree to
earn another 20 and you work your tail
end off right
yeah I would say so oh I know so I've
done it done a bunch with BTS yeah well
that's good I would just list these
debts smallest to largest I would
you know you got to have this
conversation with your parents at the
same time your name is on is your name
on it at all no not on Parent Plus Loans
okay so I would start with the 112 yes
and I would list those from smallest to
largest I'd just go crazy go ham on
those and then this Parent PLUS thing
here's the thing their name is on it
your name is not on it so
you need to speak with them it's not
gonna blow up your credit if this is
kind of an ongoing you know conversation
it's not going to stop you from doing
what you need to do
um but that's going to be tough Dave
because they might have interpreted two
different sizes whatever comes out I
mean if you guys if you decide you're
gonna pay it then you got 212 000 and
you make 90. with overtime and extra
jobs and you're single and you live on
nothing like a graduate student and so
we throw 50 a year at it in four years
you're done yeah or in or in two years
you're done if Mom and Dad pick up the
parent plus but you're probably picking
up at least some of it it sounds like in
this conversation
yeah you don't have a legal obligation I
don't really feel yeah both of you
should have your tail kicked for not
having a clear understanding before you
take out a hundred thousand dollars
worth of loans and don't know how
they're going to get paid but now that
that's done you now you got to get good
drive to Clarity and decide what you're
going to do or what you should do
technically legally you owe nothing I'd
at least try to go 50 50 though I feel
like I have no idea what these people
decided they were going to do and so I'm
not letting her or them off the hook so
um yeah y'all gotta get in there and
figure that part out and I just but but
either way Jade's right your 112 is
first you do not pay on The Parent Plus
Loans
um they at least get to pay the payments
until you clear the 112. that's their
part of the problem anyway yeah I would
agree and then after that if you decide
you want to take it on we'll do that or
something I don't know I'm just you're
gonna have to make this up as you go
because you didn't do it on the front
end
um this is how people end up not
speaking to each other that's what I'm
saying don't let it
it's a lot of money but I wouldn't let
it come between the relationship I mean
that sucks if she has to be the one to
well carry that okay yeah you're right
you're right but either way we just got
to work through it and the 112 is first
you live on beans and rice rice and
beans no life no you don't get to go on
vacation yes you take every time someone
offers you any kind of overtime with
your PT any kind of extra PT jobs
anywhere emergency room anything you can
do that's legal and moral go do it and
make money no eating out no vacations
you have made a mess girl and you got to
clean it up this is the formula for
getting out that's the bad news the good
news is it'll actually work and you'll
be debt free in around three years if
you go Whole Hog on this get after it
get after it that's how you do it
Jade 40 million people are facing a hard
reality in October student loan payments
are coming back yes they are turns out
that
um the president
well he's not going to do it so there
you go we'll just leave it at that we
kind of all knew that those of us that
are old like a politician lied who knew
and um to get votes yeah he's a lawyer
he's a lawyer he didn't know an
executive order couldn't do that by the
Constitution but who knew he did but
anyway you're going to get to pay your
student loans so our team wants to help
here's what we're going to do we're
going to be hosting a free live stream
situations just like hers just like
Ali's facing right that this is why
we're doing it and we're doing it
September the 12th at 7 00 p.m Tuesday
September the 12th and it's Jade who has
paid off over 200 000 worth of student
loan debt Rachel who never had any and
me who went broke so we got a lot of
credibility here there you go this is
the people these are the people gonna
get together and teach you so Rachel
Cruz Jade wash all Dave Ramsey are going
to talk about student loans how we got
here and give you a clear plan to pay
off your student loans no kidding we're
not gonna do it you're gonna do it but
we're gonna to show you how you're going
to be the hero in your journey we're
going to give you the sword and tell you
how to kill the dragon You are not alone
this is completely free go to
ramseysolutions.com studentloans and get
signed up for this it's September the
12th tell everybody you know we want to
have two or three hundred thousand
people watching this free live stream
and so we can help at least twenty
thousand of them because ninety percent
of them won't do squat but a bunch of
you need to come and watch and we'll
show you how to do it tell you the hard
truth and how we got here no kidding and
uh this is not just a wine session this
is exactly what you do just like we did
with Ali Ali can get out of hers and
it's on being on a budget get on every
dollar it's it's the stuff we talk about
and yeah you're going to hear it again
but you need to hear it again and we're
going to put it all in the context of
the student loans coming back in October
September 12th Rachel Cruz Jade wash all
Dave Ramsey gets signed up for this at
ramseysolutions.com student loans it's
going to be good that's a word I can't
wait this isn't
people to get free
this is the opportunity for real instead
of looking at
the deal now versus how you felt with
200 000. I'm living I'm living my best
life I have a life and you will too if
you do this if you sit around wait on
Washington DC
you're on dying death that's right
boy that was a nice word this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jane is in Knoxville hi Jane how are you
I'm pretty good how are you Dave better
than I deserve what's up oh needs so
much help I need one of them swords to
slay a huge Dragon I may be your
toughest case you've ever had
anyway my husband is around he's been
fixing to be 65 I'm around 59 and we
have 10 kids I'm homeschooling my last
one she's 15. anyway long story short
um I had to go to work he got really
sick and so he can't work like he used
to so I'm now working I started working
this past year and we are definitely
need help we have quite a bit of debt
and I don't know where to start so I
have a car that we made a huge mistake
and got a new vehicle and we owe about
54 maybe 53 000 on it which is I know
crazy but we didn't really have a good
vehicle for me to go to work in so I we
did something stupid so long story short
how do we that was my first question do
we sell that to try to get out of the
stat but I finally realized that we're
old enough we need to wish we had these
things in plan but I've been a
homeschool Mom all my life so this is
all new to me what's the car worth
what's your household income
almost about 85 maybe 80 to 85. yes you
need to sell it okay yes you shouldn't
have bought it yes you shouldn't have
who's got the loan
okay
how bad is your credit
it's good I have
been able to run over the credit union
or your local bank and get an unsecured
loan for fifteen thousand by a three
thousand dollar car and cover the 12 000
hole you're in and sell it
you got to borrow the amount that you're
in the hole oh
in order to sell it plus three thousand
dollars to get a car
because you got no car right no he has
his truck
his charm but we don't have a car get
you a little three thousand dollar car
to get around and you don't you don't
need forty three thousand dollar car to
go to work
forty thousand dollars on a tractor
it changed our lives two years ago
um you live on the farm
we do live on the farm that's a long
story but we can't sell it because it we
found out it's in a trust that his
parents had put in so we we take care of
it we have no money to take care of it
but what we make and so we can't sell it
so uh sell the tractor and Lease the
land
let somebody else Farm it your husband's
sick and you can't afford the tractor
and you're not making any money anyway
so the tractor leaves the land that
sounds great let somebody get another
farmer to lease it what's your husband
been growing on it
um I'm trying to think what all he does
uh corn soybeans
um they've done a lot of different stuff
too I'm not even sure I mean if it's
pretty standard deal is another Farmer
in the area Farms it and you get a
percentage of the crop as your lease
payment
that's a pretty standard arrangement I
assume that can go to you I don't know
you don't own it
I don't know if it goes to the trust or
not
no it doesn't I mean if you make money
on the farm you don't have to give it to
the trust right no we don't because we
have to pay the tax
I mean all the lands tied up in a trust
who is the parent
I'm sorry what did you say that's okay
I'm uh I'm aghast
um yes so am I this is not a blessing so
this is his family farm
his grandpa had it yes his Grandpa's
grandpa had it yes okay and so they
don't they they put it into a trust so
that it doesn't get sold that's
we didn't realize that we actually paid
money for the house when we moved here
but we did not know until after they
passed away that they actually put the
house in with the trust so we don't even
own the house
okay wow and so I assume upon your death
that the trust goes to your kids yes
they're cursed with this as well that's
yeah
wow
I guess there's no way to do anything
about it I don't know
I don't either but I'm going to see an
attorney uh and try to figure out
because I don't my obligation to a toxic
situation is pretty low
um I mean what happens to this beautiful
plan if you all just move off
you quit paying the taxes that's my
question yeah the trust will get trust
will lose it if you don't pay the taxes
because you're getting no benefit from
this thing at all no we're not and
there's no penalty on them that's why we
are where we are who is the trustee
my husband is
huh
you need to go see an attorney
okay do you recommend one that might no
I go to an estate planning attorney
there in Knoxville find ask around find
out who does good estate planning work
because this probably needs to be busted
up I hate to sell family land like this
but it has become a curse rather than a
blessing
and I love land and I love family
tradition and Legacy and I'm about as
the older I get the more emotional I get
about that kind of stuff but this has
not been a blessing to you and it's not
going to be a blessing to your kids
that's
because it's poorly structured and so
y'all need to figure out what the flip
so go yeah spend a little money on an
attorney let's get out of the car and
get out of the car deal and get out of
the tractor deal what other debt is
there
because you have so many payments you
can't breathe yeah that's right and
nothing really and nothing coming in the
sale well once you get out of that car
and tractor you'll be able to throw
something at that personal loan and
knock that out yeah and then that'll be
it
right yeah just tear that down and tear
down whatever hole we were in on the car
and you may be in a hole on the tractor
as well but um maybe you can get a
farmer to take that tractor and buy it
as a part of leasing the deal if you
want to investigate that but also
investigate uh busting up the trust
which by the way will solve the whole
problem because now you're in control of
the asset you can sell off to you know
50 acres of this and all of a sudden
you've got some money and you're debt
free so um and keep a 450 of it I mean
you'd be just fine so Dave you get in a
you somebody passes away and you're part
of a trust you're part of their will you
can't you can't just simply Decline and
say I don't want it
well you can fail to perform the things
they're asking to perform the weird
thing here is that he's the trustee the
trustees who has the control
um and so depending I'm not an attorney
but depending on how the trust is
written the trustee is supposed to
execute the terms of the trust but also
the trade if somebody's going to break
it up it's going to be the trustee and
her husband's a trustee yeah so if it
was some third party attorney or his
uncle or somebody was the trustee
then he you know you might not be able
to get anywhere with it but when you're
the trustee of your own trust I mean
that's
yeah so um somebody was trying to do
something good and honorable and nice
and keep them keep it in the family but
uh instead they handcuffed the family
yeah and um have left them in a toxic
situation so that's what you've got to
be careful of of these things that go in
perpetuation you know a small example of
that that's not nearly as uh emotional
as you know we just went through the uh
if Dave dies this year meeting with my
family and with the leaders I have to do
this Monty Python meeting every year I'm
feeling much better it's just a flesh
wound and um we just talk about what
happens to sheriff Dave dies so one of
the things that one of the tenances
it's written down and that we go over in
that meeting every year is that uh
nothing that we do at Ramsey Solutions
is to be kept alive because it was
Dave's dream
okay that's good you're set free from
sacred cows that's good you should put a
bullet in all sacred cows and eat them
turn them into hamburger although you
would not he's gonna say do we have to
eat them Dave can we I want to eat them
but you I'll be dead and you're a vegan
turn it into a leather jacket how about
that there we go now we're talking get
some use out of that burger out of that
Beefalo but anyway yeah the the sacred
Tech cows and that's that's what these
things become especially generationally
like this yeah where you're like four
generations down and what you can't have
the foresight to know what what's going
to happen I wanted to turn my I turned
the kids loose and the Ramsay team loose
from doing something that I thought was
good 30 years ago or 20 years ago kill
it move on I want to turn loose
emotionally and legally yeah you go to
the next thing go go to what God has
given you to do that's good this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
Jade Washington Ramsay personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five John
Asheville North Carolina hi John how are
you
I'm good how are you better than I
deserve how can I help
so
um I'm in a situation
um it's a lot of debt and I was I'll
just start running the numbers by you
um so I'm a first year physical therapy
student I still have two more years to
go of schooling I myself am in 78
000 of debt
um my fiance and soon-to-be wife is in
20 through Sally May 220 000.
um and also another 88 000 through uh
FAFSA student loans so
totaling all that up it's about 400k ish
what's she studying
she just finished physical therapy
school
um she's been working now for two months
she just started working in June
um she spent wait a minute she spent 200
000 dollars
and another 88. she spent 300 000 PT
degree why I
I know and for the longest time in our
relationship
um
I had school choice I mean what was the
deal no it's I mean it was it was a
state school
um up in Pennsylvania
um but
I don't think her family says much they
have five kids and I know they recently
just got out of debt to my knowledge
um okay so she's gotten her first job
what's she making 80.
she's making 74 before taxes is she
gonna
earns more than the average no
the only thing she could do is get a
travel job which tend to pay closer to
if you would extrapolate it out closer
to 100K a year 90 to 100K a year however
with me being in school in Asheville for
the next two years approximately when
are you getting married um
or getting married in December good okay
all right well I mean the the the the
the thing you do John is the ratio
you're looking at is and this is this
reason we ask these questions every time
is
um if you get out you're making 75 she's
making 75 that's 150 and you're going to
have 400.
so that's the shovel to whole ratio we
always call it in other words your
shovels your income the hole is 400
right
right okay so how quick do you pay off
400 making 150 well if you live on 50
and you put 100 to four years right
that's how we do it I mean that's how we
run the math there's just big numbers
like that because we don't ever we
always want to assume you live on
nothing and you put everything I mean if
you could live on 30 and put 120 it cuts
it down by a few months you know but uh
and you pick up some OT which both of
you can do pick up some emergency from
emergency room
um and anything else you can pick up
that's not travel right but um she can
make another 20 working OT working some
overtime for somebody
um it's available and um and it it can
be done and then you just plow your way
through it I mean if you guys get if
both of you make 90 instead of making 75
or both of you make 95 instead of making
75 when you get out then that's how
you're going to plow through it but it's
going to be because you're not getting
out for another 18 months after marriage
or so it's going to be a long slog I
mean y'all y'all got a three four year
at least four-year program
of no life don't talk about buying a
house
don't talk about going on vacation all I
want you to talk about is how much
you're going to work and how little
you're going to spend
because the more of that you do the
faster you get out and the higher the
probability is that you do get out
because otherwise you're going to look
up 20 years from now and you're still
going to be sitting on that ex trying to
hatch it and that's my biggest takeaway
for you John don't don't let the
magnitude of this cause you to not start
because the time is going to pass anyway
and you're going to look up in five
years and five years from now or four
years from now you're either gonna look
up and this is going to be a gone thing
of the past that you used to know or
you're going to be smack dab right in
the middle of it and some of it will
have gone up do you see what I'm saying
you got to take everything you can get
on income and cut every expense you can
cut on outgo
and I mean we're talking beans and rice
rice and beans ramen noodles Tuna fishes
for broke people I mean this is what
you're broke people that's what you're
getting into it's what you're signing up
for and both of you have signed up for
it so yeah and I I wouldn't tell you to
do anything other than that I mean get
married in December and then start
working it as hard as you can work it
and you know who's paying for the
wedding
um we collectively as a couple are going
to pay
um probably a little under 10 grand and
then both families have agreed to pay
approximately 10 grand each okay that's
a nice wedding yeah okay it is and no
you're not going in debt for it so
that's good yeah no more debt and don't
tell me you got to buy a car and don't
tell me you got to buy a house you're
broke people
with lots of degrees yep and you got to
clean the mess up man I mean you got to
re-identify yourself in your mind and go
okay I got to clean this up I got to
clean this up I got to clean this up and
you just get in that mode and you can do
it you can do people do it all time Jay
did it you paid off again and it took me
longer than you John so you can do it
you can do it yeah and you started with
a lot less income that is awesome at the
beginning of it but um y'all paid off
460 something almost 500 yeah that's
right total of which almost 300 was
student loans that's right it can be
done it's a slog but put those
milestones in there build it in when we
get once we pay off this amount we're
gonna do this thing once we pay off this
amount we're going to do this thing you
don't it's not enough to get yourself
off track but you have to celebrate
those Milestones especially when you're
in it for more than two three years
you've got to keep yourself motivated by
doing that and if it makes you feel
better you can be one of those idiots
that post on the internet Dave Ramsey
won't let me have a life
seen some of those Dave because it's not
Dave Ramsey it's you yeah
you get to decide I'm not going to do it
Dave Ramsey just told you how to get out
Jay just told you how to get out you
could actually post Jade told me I can't
have a life no no no no it's it's till
Dave do us part not till Jade do us part
whoa come on you can throw me on the bus
You're Gonna Leave Me by myself on the
mean internet memes
I don't know Dave I don't know if I can
handle it I'm thinking I think you ought
to get I think they ought to come on you
guys put it out there jade made me do it
Jade's ruined my life is this because
you didn't get the the slash Jade this
last one it's I'm still bitter you're
right you're bringing up stuff from five
weeks ago but I'm still bitter but yeah
the the thing is I didn't ruin anybody's
life I just told you to go ruin your own
life so you could get your life back
because you sold it to Sally May you
sold your butt to Sally May you signed
the deed to your butt and you handed
your deeded butt over to Sally May and
now you got to get your butt out of Hawk
yeah and that's what it amounts to and
it's a pain in the butt yeah it's not
easy a lot of butts going on here a lot
yeah you put them in there but it's not
the point is the point is there's
nothing easy about this you can try to
look for a a loophole or an easier way
out but when you've got this kind of
debt you have to sacrifice to win
there's no no two ways about it and the
weird thing guys for everybody out there
John included congratulations on the
December wedding uh we just signed you
up for hell uh not the marriage but the
uh the process of getting out of debt
there afterwards but yeah but uh for
everybody John included the interesting
thing is what happens inside of your
spirit while you're fighting through
this Bingo Jaden Sam
are a power couple to be reckoned with
they probably would have become that
anyway but they became that more so by
fighting this fight the transformation
and the calluses that happen in your
character that cause you to be able to
hold your breath grit your teeth and
push through hell and get it cleaned up
set the stage for you to be able to
tackle anything after that yeah you
can't you can't get between us and at
this point
there's nothing there's nothing you can
tell me that I'm gonna go I don't know
if I can do that it just builds this
muscle of belief of it's like when a
woman has a baby you can't tell her
nothing after that it's like I can do
anything and it's the same way when you
pay off this debt you can't tell anybody
nothing after they pay off 460 000 a day
exactly exactly and that's what it's
gonna do but but it the the force that
causes that piece of coal to become a
diamond is this extreme sacrifice in a
short period of time and it causes not
only the debt to go away but a wonderful
permanent change in your relationships
and in your life that's the beauty of it
so embrace the suck man lean into it
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we help people build wealth
do work
they love
and create actual amazing relationships
Jade wash all Ramsay personalities my
co-host today the number is
888-825-5225 that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five Megan is in
Colorado Springs to start this hour Hi
Megan welcome to the Ramsay show
hi guys happy Monday happy Monday to you
what's up
all right I have a quick question for
you my car is totaled from hail damage
in my insurance evaluated it and there's
two options one take the total off
settlement
um in a higher check and then I would
purchase a different used car or a lower
check and have it as a salvage title
how much is the car worth
um fifteen thousand so they're going to
give you a fifteen thousand dollar check
well actually I had added
um a 20 car replacement assistant so
it's actually if I do the total loss
it'll be 19 Grand if I do the salvage
title it'll be 13 Grand did you have um
did you have uh uh
alone on the car
no it's paid off
good for you that is good okay take the
check the bigger take the big one yeah
what would be the purpose in taking the
small one wait a minute yes here's the
alternative here's the alternative and
it's easy for you to figure out this is
how this how I made the decision that
fast okay
if you had nineteen thousand dollars in
your hand
would you go buy
a six thousand dollar hail damaged
salvaged car
salvage title for your driving car
no I didn't think so
it's the same thing it's the same
decision you now have nineteen thousand
dollars in your hand and they want you
to buy this car for six thousand bucks
no thank you
I'll pass it the only thing is that
they'll they're gonna tow it if I take
the 19 000. so thank you
so what you got nineteen thousand
dollars I think you can go rent a car
and then go buy one
rent your car for a week and go look
around find your car
there you go yeah they can have it
that's it's theirs once you take the
money but yeah they it's their car they
buy it
um and you can probably actually
negotiate like you know a little bit of
distance between the time they give you
the the you know pick it up in a week
give me a week to get another car after
you give me my check just work on them
work on them a little bit but if even if
they don't just go rent your car but you
you don't want that car darling um
no you're right
were you trying to do something else
with the money do you have debt to pay
off or it was just this is that on that
well no I'm on I'm on baby step three
and it's drivable it just has a lot of
dents on it yeah
yeah it looks like it looks like a
teenager with acne come on Dan
we're sorry
it's bad I had a car like I had a friend
of mine did that there was one there was
two guys here working here years ago and
we used to have two of those cars that
had the hell beat the hail beat out of
them there you go um in the uh they were
sitting in the parking lot they look
like they've been shot with an AR oh man
oh my gosh on Full Auto but yeah it was
uh it was amazing no no you don't want
that that's
even if you don't spend 19 on a car if
you want to go buy a 13 000 car that's
okay uh but just get one that doesn't
look like that I mean yeah yeah it's
yeah you can't the problem with this
other car is you can't get rid of it
once you got it and you got six thousand
dollars tied up in it I wouldn't do it
yeah I wouldn't do it that's good hey
good good question I haven't had that
one in a while open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
David's in San Antonio hi David how are
you
I'm doing great thanks how are you today
better than we deserve how can we help
so I've uh got a couple questions first
one I'm I'm getting close to finishing
baby step two
um I can see the Finish Line it's maybe
weeks or even a couple of months away
um I've been doing the baby steps I
guess for about three years now I didn't
even know I was doing them uh I've also
been saving as well and I'm ready to
move to baby step three but I'm just
scared okay
um I admit I do still use a couple of
credit cards but I pay them off in full
every month uh I know you're not a big
fan of credit scores but I'm rocking
about 800. I don't care I had it okay
you said you know I'm not a fan I really
don't I know I know
um I had a couple of expensive trips
over the summer most of it's paid for I
have one last credit card bill due David
you were doing nothing we teach why are
you asking Our advice
well
um here's the thing
um I've got about
I have a student loan to the tune of
about 6 300 and change
um now I have five thousand dollars in
treasury bills and I just moved that
over to my savings account down the
street at my credit union with what I
had in there already I'm sitting on
about 8 800 in liquid cash okay
um so so take a trip
um do I take a trip or do I just drop a
nuclear bomb on my student loan and my
credit card and be done with it
I mean what do you think what do you
think we might say
I'm pretty sure I know what you're going
to say you do know David you know what
we're gonna say David David
um during my savings come on David don't
play yourself
you know I mean I will drain my savings
and I can rebuild it I mean I'm I've you
definitely can read it I make enough to
put money away every month how much do
you make but I'm just uh I'm working two
jobs right now combined about 48k okay
um and I'm applying for for another job
um and all sarcasm aside I am really
curious why when you don't do anything
else we say do you care what we think
that is a good question
you seem to be an authority on this so
well I know but but I'm an authority on
the other stuff you're doing and you
weren't doing it and you knew that and
so I'm I'm not trying to be mean I mean
you kind of have to decide who you is
you know and fair enough okay and so
um I I don't mind it doesn't offend me
I'm gonna go on with my life you're
going to go on with yours so we'll still
be friends you know I love you I'm glad
your life is good but the if you pick
and choose on the buffet of what we lay
out in front of Ramsey all the Ramsay
things and you pick and choose you
really you could almost get yourself in
trouble mm-hmm because you sort of do it
sort of do this sort of do that sort of
this and then I'll you know you're you
know you're going to run those credit
cards back up statistically yeah there's
a 90 chance you're gonna go back in
credit card debt because you still
honestly think a credit score is a good
thing because you're proud of it you
still honestly think while you've got
this debt that it's okay to travel
you still honestly are wondering whether
you ought to cash out your savings and
put it towards it those are honest
discussions in your head but I can just
tell you from from having done this for
30 years where all of those things are
going to lead you and you can't just do
one of them and keep doing the other two
or three and end up in a good place dude
and we love you too much to not tell you
the truth so
um you'll be wondering I really would
not pay off your debt with this money
unless you're going to cut up your
credit cards and start living on less
than you make
and plug in responsibility to the whole
thing if you're not gonna do the whole
thing please don't do just a little of
it it can bring you arm
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today today's question of the
day is brought to you by neighborly your
hub for Home Services
when you're looking to buy a home and
need professional inspection trust the
neighborly brand house semester from
plumbing and electrical to Roofing and
Siding they inspect a home top to bottom
to help you make an informed decision
schedule a visit with housemaster on
neighborly.com today today's question
comes from Jeremy in Arizona I'm having
a mini dilemma over my finances and
could use a neutral third party I have
some student loans to pay off and I
could have it all paid off by now but I
held off when I thought I could qualify
for Biden's student debt relief plan I
was prepared for that possibility and am
still able to pay off my remaining
balance I've heard that the Biden
Administration is supposedly working on
another Avenue for debt relief while I
know logically that paying off my debts
sooner rather than later is the Smart
call I know there's a part of me that
will feel cheated
if I pay these loans now and find out I
would have been approved for Relief
later I feel like I know what you'll say
but as I said I'd feel better to hear it
from a neutral third party I don't know
that I'm neutral I just think that you
need to pay your bills off you need to
pay your student debt you've got the
money sitting there pay your debt
there's no relief coming
there is no relief coming I'm telling
you the relief the only relief there is
is 30 years from now when you're about
to retire and you've worked your whole
life paying and then maybe just maybe
there's a small chance depending on who
might be an administration at that time
depending on who might decide that they
want to make themselves look good
politically there might be a sliver of a
lightning Bolt's chance that you might
get a little bit of forgiveness
who wants to live their life like that
not me I like Dave I like being in
control in my life I like knowing that
if Jade says she's gonna do it she's
gonna do it I will not and you shouldn't
either live your life with this debt
hanging over your head because when you
do this and this is not just to Jeremy
this is to anybody who's holding on to
debt thinking that there's a a sliver of
a chance of a possibilities chance that
you might get forgiveness you your body
feels that
your body knows you're in debt uh Dr
John would say it all the time your body
keeps the score you know when you've got
fifty thousand dollars in debt that's
why I eat a hundred thousand dollars of
debt that's why even these uh these
payment plans that they have set up and
they're telling you hey it's okay you
can just pay 12 a month in the interest
rule in a crew you think you can't feel
the fact that you still owe a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars of debt
absolutely and let me tell you what else
you can feel Jeremy
um the guy who's out there that's a
welder
uh the gal that's cutting hair
they shouldn't have to pay your bill
you know who pays it if you don't
taxpayer
they didn't sign up for your debt you
signed up for son
you pay your bill you owe it you owe it
it's a moral and an ethical obligation
you need to pay it
quit waiting around the government to
fix your life
10 years from today 20 years from today
you will be where you are based on who
you count on do you count on your
efforts and God's blessings or do you
count on Washington D.C the people that
count on Washington DC their life sucks
if you sit around and wait on the
government to fix your life you're going
to be standing in the DMV line the rest
of your life
that's stupid
your night doesn't work waiting on
politicians to deliver the goods
you will be waiting on your deathbed for
it
they just don't do it let me tell you
who delivers the goods Jeremy you do
get up off your assets and go to work
and pay your bill you owe it
and that guy who's a welder that girl
who's cutting hair she don't owe your
money and she shouldn't have to pay it
the taxpayer shouldn't carry your burden
you're not poor
you're just leaning towards socialism
because some stupid college professor
who studied more Karl Marx than he has
capitalism influenced you at some point
that's a word you got to get off of it
pay your dad gun bill it's that simple
now we got social media stirred up here
we go boys and girls light it up
children's all right Skye is with us
Skye is in Biloxi Mississippi hey Skye
how are you
I'm doing good today thank you sure yeah
better than we deserve how can we help
um I'm pretty much
no balled myself over the last 18 months
until a lot of credit card debt got out
of it and got right back in it how'd you
do that and what'd you do
um bought a house and remodeled it you
sell the house yet
well that was an option and Oh I thought
you meant you were flipping it I
misunderstood okay how much credit card
debt have you got
um 65 000. all for remodeling
um no honestly probably 30 35
000 of it is from remodeling it the
other stuff is probably from traveling
and trying other different business
Adventures Adventures that just didn't
all work out how old are you
um 44. what do you make
uh so
I I'm right now I'm making 88 about 8
800 a month but about 3 500 is coming
from a job that I'm probably not going
to have in another couple more months I
do all contract work
what do you do I do accounting work
bookkeeping okay so you go get another
one if that contract falls out you let
go get another I'm trying so what's that
I'm trying you haven't lost it yet what
what's where are you today what's your
question
um so I know bankruptcy is not an option
I don't know
um not even close like 8 800 a month you
have 65 000 in debt you're not bad I
know and it's I guess it's just being by
myself and trying to pay all the bills
it's hard
okay you're out of control and scared
but you're not bankrupt
that'll hold us I should call these and
like negotiate
are they in collections
um some of them are how far behind are
you
four months how much is your car payment
um I'm not I pay on my house out in my
car note how much is the car payment
485. and what do you owe on the house
171 and what's it worth
um
when I bought it a year ago
I I don't know fixed you put 35 Grand
fixing it up correct what do you think
it's worth
Well the lady the realtor that came over
says that she doesn't think I could sell
it for you know 210 what I would really
want to sell it for to get recoup my
calls from it I'd like to but I'd like
to yeah in realities different things
like two doesn't establish price okay so
you got 200 000 household 171 on it and
um that won't even give you your money
back because you did a bad deal correct
yes and you're four months behind on
credit cards you have a 400 car payment
and you make 8 800 a month for now but
you're afraid you're gonna lose one of
these contracts and you're scared and
out of control is that a good summary
correct yeah been there and done that
it's no fun is it I'm sorry honey
I'm sorry
we can help you if you're willing to
embrace it I can show you how to fix it
okay
definitely you're not bankrupt hon
you've just been making a lot of for
something is causing you to make huge
moves in impulsive manners like you're
lurching around
like like the travel the travel wasn't
logical as broke as you were but you did
it anyway
correct and the car wasn't logical but
you did it anyway
yes I needed a vehicle at the time and I
that's it that's what you went over but
you went overboard
yes and the house wasn't logical at the
time but you did anyway so you've gotta
there's something causing your
decision-making process the
impulsiveness of it I know this because
I've done it myself and that's how I
recognize it but it was 30 years ago but
I can still smell it in the air on you
the impulsiveness is causing your uh
Financial
snowball it's piled up on you is what it
is it's like a piled up over your head
and then you wake up and you have a
moment of reality and it's freak out
moment you can't breathe
exactly correct yeah I thought so hun
okay here's what we're gonna do I'm
gonna put you with a financial counselor
you're not bankrupt you just need a game
plan and you've got to quit lurching
around no more impulsive decisions
okay slow gentle wise decisions from
this point forward I'm going to pay for
the financial counselor it's not gonna
cost you a thing and we're going to put
you in the Financial Peace University
it's not going to cost you a thing when
I was your age I was more broke than you
are because of similar habit patterns
you got to stop it to clean it up this
is the Ramsey Show
thank you
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Chase and Shelby are with us
hey guys how are you great how are you
guys better than we deserve where do you
all live Fort Worth Texas Fort Worth
Texas all right good for you and I
understand from our producers that
Shelby you paid off all your debt before
y'all got married uh and so
um you know we got Shelby up here just
to prove that he's the husband he didn't
do anything he's just he's just my
Michelle pieced he's the uh he's the eye
candy right there we go all right all
right good very cool all right Shelby
how much debt did you pay off before you
got married 79 000. good for you and how
long did that take about 34 months good
for you and your range of income during
that time started with 60 and ended with
95. cool what do you do for a living I
am a speech language pathologist
very good and what kind of debt was the
79 all student loans okay so how old
were you uh when you started this three
years ago it was right after I graduated
grad school so I was 24. 24. okay and so
you're 27 and you finish and how long
were you all engaged uh just about a
year we got married in June okay so
Shelby has got this girl he's going out
with and she's not buying anything ever
because she's getting out of debt and
he's like what in the world pretty much
how did this conversation go when y'all
were dating seriously well we knew each
other a little bit before we started
dating so it kind of came up really
early but we had done each other
um but I do remember I said something
about Dave Ramsey and he just
immediately like bad-mouthed you and I
was like
he said okay maybe there's hope
um but I think I just remember telling
him he was like guessing how much loans
I had and he just his jaw just kind of
dropped and but I said but like I'm I'm
on this plan like I'm gonna get this
taken care of like I'm out of debt um
and so I have to give him a lot of
credit too because he was very much
prepared to like take on the debt when
we got married if I still had something
cool so okay well that offsets the Dave
Ramsey stuff exactly he made
we're gone
no well you just say a few words for the
folks who have 80 000 of student loan
what What Makes You Different why did
you look at this and say I can do it
versus looking for any other way out I I
mean like I took it out like yes I
needed to pay it back I mean it was for
my degree I I chose to go to an out of
state grad school so that was my choice
um and so just responsibility for it and
I knew
I knew I'd be able to
just live better after like I just I
wouldn't have to work that yeah it's
it's absolutely worth it man love to
hear it yeah yeah that's very good well
I mean you could take care of it are you
and Shelby could take care of it and
you're not waiting on Joe Biden I mean
this is a good plan it's a good plan
yeah it's really nice too like in our
marriage I mean we're on babysit 3B so
we're just we're not having to worry
about it we don't have to worry about
any debt so it's saving for a house
exactly yeah same for a house okay so
you're in your mid-20s coming out of
grad school you're tearing through this
hard 36 months what do you tell people
34 months the key
to getting out of debt is oh gosh
gosh I had one key to be honest like I
just oh I've got it backwards
tell me I got the names wrong oh
Shelby's the girl chases the guy yeah
that's right I got this so screwed up
why didn't y'all correct me Dave you're
getting Chase more reasons not to
I mean I just kept hearing Shelby I
wasn't really paying attention you're
just going with it yeah
oh for me it was really big I needed to
see it I needed to pay like allocate
money to my debt first before then I
could allocate to other things
um
and so I think budgeting was the biggest
thing for me man okay yeah okay and you
got out and got the new job immediately
with a degree
I mean yeah I moved I did side hustles I
got some career advancements at my job
um so that that all helped into the
increase amazing yeah make it sound so
easy I know it wasn't I sold my car oh
let's hear more about that oh I cried
um the car didn't have any debt but I
got a great opportunity for my company
to have a company car and so I I sold my
personal car Shelby you get it you just
get it now I have to call Dave and
George to really talk me through it wow
what was the car worth sixteen thousand
oh wow so that leapfrogged it though it
did it did and that's and that too I
think is really what put me over the
edge to be able to get out of debt
before we got married yeah
um so but he was prepared I mean we were
going to be debt-free in the airport on
the honeymoon because he was saving
money
um while we were engaged but but we
didn't have to that's wonderful I love
it I love it very well I just love you
can hear it in your voice you can hear
that you're free oh yeah this was worth
it it's joyful I mean anybody listening
can hear it we can see it all over your
face it changes it changes you yeah it's
great I mean I
it's been so much it's been it was a
hard journey
um
what was the hardest part selling your
car or was there another selling my car
was really hard um as I loved my car but
I think
um just doing the side hustles there
were some that were harder than others
and I had to say no and spend my
Saturdays
um doing side hustles and that was hard
uh because I felt like I wasn't getting
to do things that my friends were doing
in their 20s
um but just knowing now like what's
ahead and that we don't have to worry
about the debt still that it's worth it
and do you ever look back and go oh man
if only I had been able to buy that
dress or if only I had been able to do
that thing no and I think that's one
thing I really learned was like the
delayed gratification and thinking about
do I really need this do I want this
um and so it's just no I don't I don't
regret the dresses it worked out I had
other things in my closet there we go
yeah so Chase what's it like watching
your fiance finish this up yeah it was
um the the experience was was it was
tough to watch because they were you
know you see the emotions it's not is
she wasn't always like you know just
Airy and free like there's a lot of hard
challenging times and and I remember the
first you know the first month or so we
were dating her weekends were doing
grocery delivery
um getting her income up other ways
before the job started taking off and so
it was it was a lot to deal with and you
know you start realizing if you want to
be with if I want to be with her I need
to prepare as well so so she helped me
grow up a lot too in the time we dated I
love that
sometimes people just living well in
front of you does that that's pretty
cool that's a nice compliment well done
well said sir well said good work proud
of you who was cheering you on other
than just Chase uh my parents and then I
had a small group of friends who knew
what I was doing they didn't know how
much that I was working towards
um but my friends I had I had a friend
who would send me like odd side jobs and
she's like do you need to add to your
side hustles
so my small group of friends was
definitely they were my cheerleaders too
that's very good there you go I'll bet
your parents are proud of you yeah we're
proud of you well done very well done a
great young couple great start very cool
hey we've got the live and give box for
you that's the baby steps millionaires
book you two are on track to be there
for sure and a Total Money Makeover book
to give to one of your friends that's
fighting their way through this
Financial Peace University if you two
hadn't been through that together as a
couple you ought to uh it's free and if
you if you don't then give it to
somebody any of it's good it's all there
for you to say thank you for coming from
Fort Worth to do your debt free scream
here
all right it's show
with Chase and Tow I love it 79
000 paid off before the marriage did it
in 34 months making 60 to 95 count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one
[Applause]
it's how it's done man
yeah wow these dating conversations are
interesting to me oh yeah I mean it's
like you're doing Dave Ramsey if you're
not heard about him yeah ooh gross ooh
I mean that's the kind of stuff that
comes out yes you can see you see at the
social media feed oh yeah you know so
it's it's funny and then but you got to
be careful because you might be talking
to like a Ramsay fan that's true
somebody whose life has been changed and
then you just ruined the day well yeah
yes that's right you got to know who
you're dating
like talking politics I mean if you get
you in trouble oh
you mean you know what
you mean you voted wrong what I mean
come on
on the first day tell them who you voted
for and say Dave Ramsey and see what
happens just yeah you can pretty much
that's a great screener system there and
did they pay cash for dinner this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
here I'm a huge fan of both meditation
and prayer and good mental health
includes slowing down gaining control of
your thoughts and plugging into
something bigger than you and Halo makes
it easy to start a daily practice of
meditation prayer and finding peace
Hollow is the number one Bible app in
the world and you can tailor content
towards your faith tradition from
scripture readings and prayers to
meditation and journaling hallow makes
it easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com Ramsay today to get three
months of hallow for free that's
hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Bayla is with us in
Cincinnati hi Bayla how are you
I'm doing wonderful Dave thank you so
much for taking my call I'm super
excited about this and uh let's uh let's
Jump Right In here so okay
um uh I'm a long time listener and a
very short time putting into actioner
okay
that being said I have a an idea for a
business plan LLC independent contractor
uh side hustle and I'd like to know how
to do what I'm going to do currently I'm
employed with the state of Ohio and
um I work for the hard apartment natural
resources
also and I make 43 000 annually and
what's the side hustle idea
all right that's the idea is a
management plan I have a degree in
wildlife management and
um it's it's it's Goose management
so I have a dog he's my best friend his
name is Arlo he's a border collie oh
yeah I know the dealer yeah yeah I've
got some friends in New York the state
that have uh they've got six squads of
Border Collies and the local government
contracts with them to run the geese
is that what you're talking about and I
so so I work for the state government
okay yeah and I I'm very connected and
you know I would I would volunteer my
time to the state government uh
especially like parks and watercraft I'd
have to volunteer my time because it's
conflict of interest exactly but I I'm
allowed to do that
um as long as because it doesn't it that
doesn't uh meet my that that isn't part
of my job my my jobs job duties what's
the state
um so you're not allowed to volunteer
you know if it's right if it falls in
your job duties anyway so I would like
to go into business with my dog Arlo
yeah he's going to be my business
partner and uh you know very low startup
costs and uh you know I need I need pet
insurance I need insurance for my
business I need insurance for my truck
you know you don't need any of that
I don't need business insurance no you
and the dog are gonna go run geese it's
not rocket science
go run the geese
you're not gonna wreck the dog and
you're not going to wreck your truck
you got you got insurance on the truck
now right
absolutely all right just put the dog in
the truck go run geese
it's really it's not it's not harder
than that right and collect a check yeah
I would no you don't need to overthink
this or you're not doing anything that's
going to create any liability that dog's
not going to bite somebody that's not a
biting dog
that dog's a herd dog
yeah right right right right yeah so I
mean it's a great dog the only thing the
one thing I would be worried about is
like him running out into traffic and
and causing an accident or something you
know what I mean
um which I don't think will happen but I
don't either I mean yeah you're you're
you know
if it does all of that you're a state
employee with no assets nobody's going
to bother you you got the dog you know
if my you know if what if your dog runs
out in traffic now and causes an
accident even if it wasn't in in the
pursuit of a business you know it'd be
the exact same thing you don't have dog
insurance for that
but it but if it is my business and it
doesn't matter yeah okay unless you're
making 20 million dollars a year and
then you need insurance and you need an
LLC but you're you're not making 20
million dollars a year doing this
yeah you end up with a whole bunch of
these dogs doing this you can end up
with a legitimate big time thing so
here's what I would do keep it very
simple you'll run it as a sole
proprietorship go to the bank and open a
separate checking account with your
current social security number uh
your first your full name DBA it's
called a DBA account doing business as
well
Patrol or Arlo's Arlo's uh I already
have a name picked out oh yeah okay all
right then put it in the doing business
as the name whatever the name is right
and then any money you make
from
geese chasing you put into that account
do not put it into your personal account
and then any expenses you have
associated with that business which will
be very limited expenses maybe a little
gasoline in the truck to go to the job
site right miles and wear and tear yeah
if you want to do a little bit of that I
wouldn't I wouldn't get too carried away
but whatever the real cash expenses are
whatever's left in that account then is
your profit when you pull money out of
that account because it gets a little
bit in there and you want to take it
home to pay bills with you set aside a
fourth of it to another account
for taxes is that another like a savings
account yeah just another little savings
account and that's just uh Bayless tax
account is nicknamed okay because you
got to set aside you got to withhold on
yourself
because there's nobody withholding on
you and you're supposed to file
quarterly estimates after you've been
open a year
okay so I'm an independent contractor
and it's like 10.99 correct and that's
what exactly and so you're you're
running a business and businesses have
to file quarterly estimates whether
they're an LLC a sub s or a sole
proprietor you're a sole proprietor the
only reason to open an LLC is if you
start being worried about liability and
the only reason to be worried about
liability is if you have a bunch of
money like if you're a rich Uncle leaves
you a million dollars then do an LLC or
if your business gets big enough that
it's got a Target on it because
everybody wants to sue everybody for
something
right yeah but you got no target it's a
guy on his dog in a truck chasing birds
it's not a Target how much money do you
make on that
uh uh you know there's a similar company
that is local to my uh so there's a
little bit of competition but not much
he has he has a crew in Dayton a crew in
Cincinnati and a crew in Columbus and I
almost got hired with him to go do the
Columbus route but it's too far it was
too far for me it didn't make sense and
uh I turned it down you just go go do a
run what once a day or once twice a week
or whatever yeah he said there was a
hundred thousand dollars to be made in
Columbus yeah
and then and you know uh uh a a girl
that was doing it and they had they
drive Priuses you know gas efficient
Priuses and uh you know I've seen them
do it they they pull into the parking
lot and sometimes they don't use a dog
they just walk over there they just walk
around the property and Chase the geese
off of the Bounder off off the off of
the property line so on the neighbor's
property off of the property line of the
person that they are contracted for and
then they come back and do it every
three days or two days right
and they get paid every time yeah and
the gays are back yeah that's what it is
it's just what a life it's just a
harassing uh more federally endangered
species yes
or the geese will fly over to another my
other property that I have a contract
with on the other side of the street and
I'll go over there and chase them back
to the other side and get another check
oh man man I'm just kidding it's about
how bad it is though you're right that's
the I mean that's that's essentially the
way it works but yeah you got to show us
the birds are just not smart you got to
be consistent every day or every other
day you know and then uh it's just you
know it's just uh turns out the only way
to get rid of them is illegal so there
you go
I never would have known about this
we had a guy and he was in New York
state come to entree leadership about
five years ago at one of our events and
I sat and talked to him about this
that's the only reason I knew anything
about it I just got so enamored I
thought what a great subscription
recurring Revenue business model go run
geese off that come back every three
days until you know because it doesn't
they're dumb they just keep coming back
even if the dog gets a hold of one of
them I mean they'll they they're just
done it's it's fun but yeah and and you
can't kill them because they're
federally endangered so not least
interesting and so um yeah so you're you
know you're stuck with Arlo
yeah there we go sounds like a movie it
is yeah hey man go make you a bunch of
money if you start making a bunch of
money and this gets real formal and you
want to drop an LLC on it fine I would
not go to the expense and file an extra
tax return and go through all this extra
crap just open it your social and just
start a business it's America you can
just start and go it says it's really
not anything to it it's um the good news
is we don't live in Russia you know I
think sometimes people want to start
they start businesses and they want to
do all this stuff first and you don't
even need to do all that well and here's
a here you take a guy like this a guy
with his dog chasing geese
if you're unemployed out there come on
oh my God I mean you just hurt you just
got totally shamed okay yes this is a
guy with a dog chasing geese and he's
got a business okay he's gonna make
something he's gonna make Bank on it
he's serious it's real I love it what a
country what a country America America
all things possible baby that's it man
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsay personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us if you
want to talk about your life we'll talk
about you right in front of you the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five Thomas is in
Austin Texas starting this hour Hey
Thomas what's up
hey y'all thank you so much for taking
my phone call I appreciate it our
pleasure how can we help
well um so we just started the program
my wife and I we've been married for
about five years and we've just been
struggling paycheck to paycheck
obviously and
um we just kind of got fed up with it we
had the aha moment like what are we
doing we could
um uh just making some some some tough
decisions and
um we went and started detecting the
experience and stuff like that started
finding like who we have our
um our outstanding debt with and turns
out you know I have about 11 600 in debt
which wasn't that much compared to some
of the cars that you have on the phone
so we were really aesthetic about that
then we got to my white side of things
and it turns out she's about a hundred
and sixty three thousand dollars in debt
and it wasn't something that I was
really aware of from the get-go and
um
um it's kind of a unique situation 140
000 of it is into a mortgage that her
name is on but
um in the divorce decree that she had
with her previous husband and she signed
any kind of uh all that over to him
um now she did that on the intentions of
some sort of verbal agreement that he
had with her that she he was going to
pay her out or give or buy her out with
a certain amount of money
um we've been waiting for about five
years like I said since we've been
married and we haven't seen any sort of
dime in order from that and that's this
huge debt hanging over our head and I'm
wondering does the divorce decree give
her half ownership in the house no she
signed it over
so why was he why is he obligated to buy
her out
now they have a kid together and she
lives with us and we've been taking care
of you know all of that and why is he
obligated to buy her out of the house
when the divorce decree didn't say that
obligated but as I said verbal
agreements and they're they are um there
are they're unspeaking terms it's not
like they're it's a divorce decree state
that he had to refinance the house and
get it out of her name
um no it did not
um but that's what he's saying that he's
going to do but it just hasn't but he's
under no legal obligation to do anything
pretty much know
so he doesn't have to I mean if he wants
to sell the house and give her half when
the time comes that's his prerogative
but he doesn't have to be in a rush
because this wasn't and he doesn't have
to refinance yeah
no no court no judge decreed this
right and that's what that's where the
problem lies and I'm wondering
um so what's the status of the house who
lives in the house
we actually do you live in a house that
someone else owns that's our ex-husband
correct interesting
tell me about it
uh okay that's awkward yeah that's that
feels messy
I mean like I said their relationship is
fairly decent they have a kid together
that's very um civil it's not like
they're with each other he tries to pay
child support
you're supposed to he's not very good
about it but he's been better yes what's
the house worth
um it's probably worth about 300. how
old are the kids
um she's 17.
are you I have a question about the
mortgage are you paying the actual
mortgage or are you paying a different
amount uh
we pay we pay like we paid pretty good
compared to rent prices around here we
pay 1300 a month whether that covers a
mortgage payment I'm not sure but I'm
sure it probably covers
most of it if not all of it okay so
Thomas here here's um this is messy for
everyone
it's messy for him it's messy for your
wife it's awkward for you it's even
messy for their daughter
so
um he's got another year of child
support due he's been on a he's been
unwilling or unable to pay that there's
a hundred and fifty thousand or so in
equity that he has on a handshake said
he was going to share but I'm not sure
how good his memory is because he
doesn't pay child support
regularly like he should
okay
um
and I'm not sure how good his memory is
on refinancing and so probably the only
card you all hold is uh two cards you
have a persuasion card for your wife and
maybe you're in the room I don't know
the dynamic but sit down with him in
person and say oh this is all real messy
and with her getting ready to turn 18
um we need to clean this up
okay so our uh we're gonna move
and when you sell the house
um we're we're willing to work with you
on the back child support and the missed
child support payments if you
um honor your word on getting the house
sold and on splitting it with me if
you're not gonna do that then we're
gonna go to court over the back child
support payments because we're going to
at least collect that
and you're gonna you're gonna sell the
house but I think you in other words I
think you can just free in a friendly
way just say it's time for us to put a
bow on this mess
that's a bad one put put a pin in it put
a pin in it yeah put a pin in this mess
that's better and uh the best way to do
that is to get uh get us off we're on a
mortgage together we don't need to be
there this you got this child support
hanging over your head if you'll split
the house with us like you said you
would and go ahead and get it sold and
get the mortgage gone and we get half
the equity well for no child support
from here on out you're out of child
support for the rest of the year and for
any back child support we're not going
to bother you about it but let's go
ahead and get this done let's get this
cleaned up because it's time for
everybody to go their own way this
should have been done five years ago the
attorney that these two people used was
an absolute
I don't think they use an attorney I
think they just went through this stage
so yeah I rest my case yeah they were
absolute morons yeah they there's a
horrible transaction
poorly designed everything about it was
not thought through they all thought
we're going to be friends we're going to
be friends you might end up friends
that'd be nice it'd be great if you do
I'm not trying to pick a fight but you
need to wrap this up because there's
just so much electricity in the air
asking for an explosion with child
support not hitting but you can't really
call him on it because you're not sure
he's going to keep his word on getting
the house out of her name and whether
he's going to keep his word on splitting
the house with her because he doesn't
really have to because we didn't really
put it in the divorce decree because
nobody was driving this bus as it went
off the cliff
yeah and we're not even really worried
about the child support to be honest
with you we live on our own income
that's my point so get you know use that
as leverage because you don't need it
let him out of it and that's your give
if he'll go ahead and split and go ahead
and get the house sold and get the
mortgage out of your wife's name
okay if he doesn't do all of that you're
probably going to have to hire an
attorney and force this because it's
what should happen it's Gotta you gotta
get this cleaned up you may never get
half the equity that's possible but at
least get the mortgage out of her name
because you guys aren't gonna be able to
buy a house moving forward to you get
this mortgage out of her name
uh messy messy boys and girls if you're
going to go through a divorce and do not
give the person the ownership of the
house and stay on the mortgage quit
claim deed and stay on the mortgage dumb
lazy strategy don't do that
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today last
week she did a webinar on budgeting 10
000 of you showed up thank you for that
tomorrow August the 15th Rachel Cruz
will be doing a webinar on budgeting uh
yep we're going to work through the
whole mental cycle of living paycheck to
paycheck break the Habit talk about how
to do an irregular income in a budget
every dollar is the budgeting app that
Rachel will be using to show you how to
do that it is the world's best budgeting
app produced for you by Ramsey it is
completely free to attend this webinar
tomorrow August the 15th and uh you just
simply sign up by going to
everydollar.com budgeting and Rachel
Cruz will lead you through it and also
keep that website in mind because Jade
will be doing another one George will be
doing a couple Rachel will be doing
another one so we're going to keep these
budgeting uh webinars going for a little
while because they've been so popular
completely free by the way we don't
charge you a thing we invite you to come
and to be with us so everydollar.com
budgeting Andrew is in Albuquerque New
Mexico Andrew what's up
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve how can we help I figured you'd
say that so
um my situation is
um I'm getting married in November
congratulations
thank you
um so Chrissy and I have
um very little bad debt I don't think we
actually have any basically uh she owes
about a hundred and fourteen thousand on
her house 3.5 interest
I just paid off uh or sold my house in
California
and the proceeds are about 154 000. we
have two cars nine thousand dollars each
uh Dad we're trying to figure what's
that the dad on the cars is not each
yes okay
all right and credit scores are both uh
a12. how can we help and we're trying to
figure out should we
invest some or all of that 150 into a CD
for maybe five or six years at five
percent
or should we pay off the house and the
cars in pool right away
so the way that are is this your first
time kind of listening in or how long
have you been
hanging out with us for two years
um I'm not allowed to marry Christy
until I went through uh some of the
courses
um who said that are you from her
parents they were they they actually
instructed uh Jack and Debbie instructed
for
um some of those courses okay so so then
you know the answer to your question
I do it's just the math side of me is
like okay that's about eighty thousand
dollars after six years and then if I
pay off this house
um in six years
we're really only paying about 20 000 in
interest so the net is an extra sixty
thousand that I think
it's just tempting to look at that sixty
thousand and think okay we can put that
towards a child's education
um yeah we don't have any kids we don't
have any
um
what's that you won't net that much
how much would it net your your math is
naive you left out taxes
oh okay and you left out rest
and on the positive side of the equation
yeah your formula is incomplete
um the um and the other so we studied 10
167 millionaires we put the white paper
in the back of the book baby steps
millionaires I'll give you a copy of it
okay
was my last number one it was my latest
number one bestseller all right now the
reason I tell you all of that is that in
studying millionaires the number of them
that said I became a millionaire by not
paying off my house and putting the
money in CDs and the spread made me
wealthy out of ten thousand of them the
number that did that was precisely zero
okay
which means that the data says your
theory sucks
okay
in the same way that you left out pieces
of the equation on the debt side of it
you left out pieces of the equation on
the equation of getting debt free you've
not been debt free so you don't know
yeah but you can't talk about that like
it's kind of just like this throwaway
thing that's a big big thing is the
thing we discovered under is that a
couple married you guys married and of
course you're marrying into a family
that believes this stuff so bless your
heart I mean you're joining a call
you're joining a cult Andrew but yeah
but the uh so you're marrying into this
and uh so it the when you have zero debt
and you have that incredible cash flow
as a result the two of both of your
incomes I mean oh my gosh with no debt
at all the ability to pile up and build
wealth is amazing but what ends up
happening too is relationally
statistically you're more successful
career statistically you're more
successful here's why it's a very common
sense if you think about it you don't
have to work in a bad place so it
changes your negotiating power not that
you're going to go in and throw your
weight around every three weeks and get
a raise but you just walk different when
you walk down the hall of that place and
they don't mess with you
yeah yeah right and that's why even
after that Swagger is equal more than
the spread you're talking about and that
and you know and you know we we don't
have any solid data on this but it's a
reasonable uh extrapolation to say hey
number number of uh health problems
caused by stress number one cause of
divorce and America today caused by
stress Financial stress all of these
things added together equal substantial
money really at the end of the day when
you when you cut down the number of
stress-oriented health problems because
you cut down Financial stress being the
number one stress point in America and
you get rid of career stress because you
don't have to stay in a toxic
environment because you don't have to
work to pay the man
and so all of these things start to
extrapolate and it turns into wealth
health and peace and it just that's why
we keep going back to it not because
we're naive and we don't understand you
know the the spread on the interest we
do but the spread on the interest when
you factor in all those things doesn't
even come close to taking care of it I'm
with you Dave I am with you I
got you know a lot of times
people look at these numbers and it's
like you know they're not in a ton of
debt you know it's her home it's easy to
look at other options but at the end of
the day he's got that cash they could be
debt free they can have a home paid for
no debt in the world and how like he
said how quickly could they go and do
more real estate and pay cash for it how
much can they put into their the math is
wrong too women 115 000 at five percent
is only five thousand dollars a year for
five years so it's only twenty five
thousand dollars that's not eighty
thousand dollars Andrew how'd you get
eighty thousand dollars it's not there
so you messed up something there too
five percent of a hundred thousand is
five thousand times five is twenty five
so over five years is not an eighty
thousand dollar spread
so something because and that's if your
mortgage was zero percent and you made
five percent on the CD that's a very
good so uh yeah you yeah you just you
can't move
the shell enough
to where the p is not under one of them
it's always under one of them it's just
an illusion hey man thanks for the call
and good luck with the new marriage hang
on Austin I'll pick up we'll get you
signed up for the baby steps millionaire
stuff so Jade it turns out that when God
said
the rituals over the poor the borrower
is slave
to the lender that that slavery has more
implications than
a an ancient biblical metaphor it
actually is more than that there's what
are all the implications of being a
Slave versus not being a Slave What kind
of slave can you be a mental emotional
it's like can you be a slave to your job
100 can you be a slave I mean how many
different kinds of slave are are mixed
into slave
that's pretty crazy and it gets you you
know when you get free of it is when you
know oh yeah that's when you know that
you were all of your decisions are it
all of your decisions are different yep
the way the process that you take
mentally when you make decisions
completely changes
Financial Peace
two words that don't go together
like Airline service this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
s
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Jeremy
and Jessica are with us hey guys how are
you so good yeah welcome where do y'all
live
Pensacola Florida Welcome to Nashville
thank you how much debt have you guys
paid off
about 215 000 or five years oh good for
you well excellent and what was your
range of income during that five years
about 65 to 195 or so wow cool what do
y'all do for a living
um I'm active duty Navy and registered
nurse thank you for your service thank
you for your support
I'm a registered nurse okay very cool
couple of nurses awesomeness okay what
kind of debt was the 215 all mortgage
Morgan look at their weird people
I paid for house I love it way to go you
two what's the house worth uh about 450.
nice now how old are you two I'm 54. 46.
and I paid four house I'm on somebody
hey there you go game on and how much in
your retirement accounts
we got about 240 now and but Jeremy's
got he's retired from the Navy as well
so we've got ourselves set up pretty
well yeah
did you do 20 years about 24. oh yeah
they got that nice that's good yeah it
is good very good nice retirement
program and now you're you so you
doubled your income right now yeah right
that's why we go from 65 to 195 yeah
okay that makes sense way to go guys
thank you so much way to go and you're
almost millionaires I mean again on top
of that yeah well done very well done
excellent what started this whole thing
when you're like you know what we're
just gonna pay our house off and we're
gonna get intentional about it what made
you
oh it started probably
um
10 or 11 years ago we're on the Dave
Ramsey light program where uh wow we
started with financial peace and we had
Sharon wants me to get on that program
the Dave Ramsey light I like that yeah
so we had we had the envelopes and we
did cash but only kind of um we lived
overseas for about five years we came
back bought a house and um
one day we just sat out and had a budget
meeting like a real budget meeting
Jessica's a math wizard she broke out an
Excel spreadsheet and uh started
plugging numbers in and we thought oh
man we we can really do this
I think we sat down and we realized we
make way more money than we actually
have track of so we just started having
monthly budget meetings and uh really we
make too much money to be this broke
that's right exactly that disgust will
get you to the table that's exactly what
happened yeah so about two and a half
years ago we realized you know we could
really pay off our house really pay it
off so really hammer down and five years
was 215 but really uh in the past two
years about 185 000 because we just went
here yeah we just did everything we had
to yeah so really that's what it is yeah
that's that you just when you look up
you could see the you could see the
light it's in the tunnel it's not a
train that's right so you run to the
light you know I mean that kind of
beautiful well done that's beautiful
how's it feel not having any payments
it's weird it is still kind of weird
yeah so but I think
probably the month after we paid our
house off I walked into the backyard and
I'm like every blade of grass is ours
and uh it was an amazing feeling it is
it really is well done you guys thank
you so much very well done so what's
next what do you guys do you got no
payments in the world do anything you
want to do that's right we came here
this was a vacation yeah that we really
enjoyed well good I'm glad you like
Nashville then it's yeah good A lot of
people yes there is yeah yes there is
downtown has turned into a redneck Mardi
Gras that's what we said it really has
it's out of control the Bridezillas
bridesmaids out of control they're going
nuts the whole thing but it's still it's
it's if you like people watching it's
entertaining as crud it is yeah so well
we're glad you came cool sure what's the
first big thing you're going to do with
money now that you're free
we're gonna start plugging it back into
our investing and our Roth just want to
see that roll up now huh all right yeah
look at those girls
get this compound interest going baby
I'm thinking you're gonna say a trip to
Europe a trip I gotta get this compound
interested I'm not mad at that at all
that is so fabulous well done so when
y'all were growing up did you grow up in
families that had paid for houses or uh
is this new to your family tree or what
it's brand new I mean we both grew up uh
relatively poor so owning a home was uh
a reach for us you know growing up so
it's much less having it paid for
absolutely well let us had single moms
you know oh yeah okay rough times
growing up so thank you if they're alive
they got to be proud absolutely yeah
yeah they got to be just thrilled just
smiling and going I did it this is this
is how it works out yeah some of you
single moms out there that are worried
if you're doing okay or not this is what
you're growing you're growing people
like this that's right
single moms are warriors man they're
amazing Sarah well congratulations you
two were very very proud of you what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is
uh keep your marriage focused on God and
have monthly budget meetings make a plan
and stick to it
there it is game on absolutely sounds
like a couple of nurses
if I if I prescribe you medicine take it
that's right that's right be complaining
store it up for the next time you're
sick take it oh my gosh that's it that's
the plan to execute the plan I mean
execute the plan a doc was telling me
the other day I had no idea the amount
of times he writes script and people
don't take it oh yeah what wow what the
number of un fulfilled people just don't
do what they're supposed to do stuff I
mean it's just crazy I wouldn't know
anybody like that but yeah all right so
hey we got the uh live and give box for
you the baby steps millionaires book
because that's definitely where you're
headed shortly compound interest lady
over here is going to make that happen
and Total Money Makeover book to give
away and get somebody moving and of
course
the uh Financial Peace University again
give that away it's for you to live or
give you enjoy it thank you for coming
from Pensacola and again thanks to both
of you for your service very very cool
I'm so happy that you're almost
Millionaires and you're a hundred
percent debt free house and everything
Jeremy and Jessica Pensacola Florida 215
paid off in five years 185 of that in
the last two paid for house almost baby
steps millionaires making 65 to 195
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
that's how you do it
game on yeah I love it
I love it I wonder I need to I've never
seen this we need to ask the research
team next time they're running a survey
out especially if they're running it on
the Millionaire's page
I wonder how often
two nurses become how more much more
often two nurses become a millionaire
versus one doc
oh that's a good one Dave because I see
nurses that's a good one they lean into
system I mean docs do all this crazy
stuff they're all over the place uh some
of them are really game on but most of
them are out of their minds and
um and their number the docs are number
six though and nurses aren't so I guess
the docs would come up more often but
you put two nurses or I'll tell you the
other one I see in the millionaires
that's a lot like a nurse and a police
officer um uh that kind of thing because
it's uh systems there's something about
that systems and they plug in and they
do it that's a couple nurses there okay
they sit down we can do this yeah they
didn't have an argument about it they're
just like we make too much money to be
broke let's get this done yeah game all
it's fair matter of fact very practical
it's not like some kind of big it's the
antidote there's no drama yeah you know
we got drama at work if you're a nurse
the numbers aren't a drama you know oh
that's a good tie-in they're high stress
jobs police officer nurse you have
enough to deal with that work when you
go home it needs to feel peaceful yeah
teachers have high stress because they
have to deal with the parents yeah
I could never do it I don't know these
parents that drop off their
kindergartners
I don't know how you tolerate those
parents well I'm one of those parents
Dave and and and I did it with no tears
this morning all right I did it you did
until I brought it up on the air that's
true although my son would not take a
photo with me maybe that's why I didn't
get the tears yeah no he said yeah we
got we got two of the Rams your
grandbaby started kindergarten this week
too so we're you're among friends I love
it
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture of the day is Psalm 119
105 your word is a lamp to my feet and a
light to my path Ronald Reagan said when
you can't make them see the light make
them feel the heat
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's that's good okay we can go that
way and we can go that way if you want
to well I just ran into uh Dr John
deloney in the hallway just a second ago
congratulating him on the uh huge sales
of this new book of his called building
a non-anxious life it actually comes out
October the 3rd but we've got it on
pre-sale right now for twenty dollars
and we'll throw in 75 dollars worth of
free bonus items which includes instant
access to his newest talk smoke fire and
freedom that breaks down the mythology
about anxiety and what we believe about
anxiety and help you reclaim your life
you're also going to get the ebook the
audiobook building a non-anxious life in
a burned out chronic stress
anxiety-filled culture this book is
really needed I'm so proud of him I'm so
proud of the content it's really good
stuff go to ramsesolutions.com and
pre-order it by Dr John deloney building
a non-anxious life be sure and do that
Joseph is with us in Harrisburg
Pennsylvania hi Joseph welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hello Mr Dave how are you doing better
than we deserve what's up
but that's outstanding uh so I'm 21
years old I am looking to purchase my
first property it is a
multi-family at the quad Plex
and I've run the math everything looks
good on my side based on my view but I
know you have
a lot of um real estate wisdom and
knowledge so I wanted to run it past UC
if you thought it was a good idea before
I went ahead and pulled the trigger on
it
okay so um I make go ahead yes sir you
make one
so 61 okay it's my take-home pay
um every year
um I have no debt whatsoever and the
mortgage payment as of right now
um the current rates the mortgage
payment on the property would be only
20 of my take-home pay
so my right now I have basically 20 of
your take-home pay
correct for a quad Plex
yes so it's going for 190 on the market
as once it gets on but the owner of it
he's my mentor and he's willing to sell
it to me at a discounted price because
this is something that he and I have
been talking about for a long time what
type of neighborhood is this in
it is outside of Harrisburg it's in a
small town
um
really nice that's not bad so you think
you'll be able to resell it for a profit
in five years
yes sir
I've actually
we've recently upgraded all of the units
because I'm an electrician by trade
though the company that my mentor owns
we remodeled it before we put it on the
market
for renting to begin with so all four
units are rented out and it's currently
cash flowing there is nothing wrong with
anything you're saying
um all the numbers work
uh there's a couple of things you just
want to be aware of
that um that are going to change the
deal for you and uh
as long as you're aware of them and
you're ready for them then you it won't
kill you you'll be all right the first
thing is is that um are you dating
someone seriously
no sir okay if you were to meet the
right person and get married you will
discover she does not want to live there
so be prepared for that
okay a lot a lot of guys go buy a house
and
um and even a nice house you know like a
nice little cute little single-family
home and uh but something about the the
new wife doesn't want to live in The
Bachelor Pad you know they don't want to
come back they don't want to live there
so just be prepared for that number one
number two the uh good news is your
tenants are next door
so you know what's going on the bad news
is your tenants are next door
I would not be living in it
oh
that's what I wanted to ask I wanted to
ask if you were living and I wanted to
ask if you can still afford it if
the other three tenants don't pay but if
you're not living there I feel like that
changes the equation a little bit so the
payment if nobody pays the payment is 20
of your take-home pay
if nobody pays anything the mortgage is
still 20 of my take-home pay that would
also cancel out utilities I would still
have tax that would probably go up okay
well where are you living and what do
you pay for where you live
right now it's just me and a roommate we
pay 8.50 a month we live in um
a property that one of our friends owns
so the eight let me throw one more set
of numbers so you're 850 and then if the
tenant and then the from the tenants
that all that money is what what
percentage does that put you at yeah
um I don't think I understand what you
just said you're a portion if you have
to pay rent and the payment
your portion of the rent because you're
splitting with a roommate but you're is
the 850 year portion
no no no that's okay so you pay half
that you'll pay 400. wow yeah plus well
I pay half of 750 we also have I have a
brother that doesn't live there but he
still pays rent to keep it okay so
you're paying 350. I am paying 350. okay
we've been there for a while and we're
good friends with the owner and this is
not horrible but it's not as exciting as
I think it is in your head
I'm also wondering about the longevity
of it how long you're going to want to
live in this situation I just think
something's going to change here I would
rather you be buying a home you lived in
uh personally overall and um so uh
Joseph I got my real estate license when
I turned 18. I went to the University of
Tennessee at Knoxville and I got a
degree in finance and in real estate I
was selling real estate in a small town
south of Knoxville called Maryville
Tennessee merval Tennessee if you're
from there if you're a Yankee you call
it Maryville but um
and I found this really cute little
house that needed a little bit of work
and I knew how to do work because I grew
up like you did knowing how to wire a
box or swing a hammer and um it needed
about a couple thousand dollars worth of
work I could buy the house now this was
a thousand years ago okay this is 1982.
I could buy the house for nineteen
thousand dollars and um I could qualify
for the mortgage because I've been
selling real estate I made enough money
I was working full-time and going to
school full time and I almost bought
that house and I was uh I was 20
and a half I wasn't quite 21 yet and uh
my mentor at the time talked me out of
it who owned a real estate company that
I worked for his name is Gary Gary was
the broker and we believe in real estate
we sell real estate for a living and he
said you don't want to do that right now
you're getting ready to graduate from
school you might get married and you
might leave
and not be living here and you're going
to have this house and it's going to be
more of a curse and it is a blessing now
that's not your case but my point is I
was very young and I didn't buy that
piece of property and a thousand times
I've thanked Gary for that huh that I
didn't buy it because it it there was
nothing wrong with the deal but it just
my what was wrong was all of the My
phase of Life made the deal less fun and
I'm not saying you're gonna get married
and change cities Joseph at all so your
story doesn't parallel my the only part
of my story that parallels yours is I
was the same age as you I was young you
were pretty young to be owning a quad
Plex while you're a renter so you're a
real estate investor and a renter that's
just kind of weird and awkward it felt
better if he was living there yeah and
even that I had some qualms about if I'm
being honest yeah I'm just I worry about
you doing I mean you can do it and I'm
not saying young people can do stuff
that's not my point at all but my point
is you're at a stage of life when things
change pretty quick the next five years
there's gonna be more changes than any
other five-year period of time in your
future probably yeah so um that's
something to consider but it is hey
you're a sharp young dude you'll figure
it out it sounds like you got a good
Mentor and he's being generous to you
that's good so hope it works out for you
brother thank you for the call that puts
this hour the Ramsey Show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
foreign
[Music]
ER you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]